[Music]
well the party going strong at the Clark
County block party tonight that is one
of the immersive art pieces brought in
and Las Vegas local Frankie Perez
performing a little bit earlier tonight
this is happening at a historic part of
Las Vegas not too far from Sahara and
Maryland Parkway Sasha Loftus has been
out there since before the gates open
and now has a an update for us as the
crowd went and how was the whole event
Denise it was quite the night here at
Commercial Center things wrapped up
about a half an hour ago or so but you
can see it was quite the party they're
tearing everything down right now now
those behind this particular event say
they hope it's the first step to bring
new life to this area
ringing in a new era for a piece of Las
Vegas history and it's nice to see it
coming back thousands poured into
commercial center for this massive block
party
featuring Mix Master Mike of the Beastie
Boys and the main headliner dead mouse
the event which also featured local
vendors and food trucks had a bit of an
EDC meets first Friday Vibe bringing my
friends here to see that the energy had
many thrill to soak in the excitement
while also remembering what this Plaza
which was built in the mid 60s used to
be I remember the state Frank was right
there over here was the pool hall and my
parents and I used to come to the
commercial center back in the 70s and
80s when we were growing up Clark County
Commissioner tick segerbloom says that's
the main goal of this event we wanted to
have fun but we're really trying to let
people know commercial center is Alive
and Well he and other organizers want to
give this spot more exposure as they
work on pushing towards its potential
future it's close to the strip there's
no other place as this much land that's
ready to be developed this as those here
do their best to celebrate and soak in
all it has to offer now a little bit of
that EDC energy in this in this area
that needs to be lifted up
now Clark County officials say they hope
to hold similar events like this here at
Commercial Center in the future there
were also quite a few booths with local
art vendors things like that similar to
what you see at First Friday reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now